- Dans une rare sortie à
l'extérieur de la capitale,
Volodymyr Zelensky s'est rendu
dans le sud du pays.
Le président a profité
de son passage à la base
de la Garde nationale à Odessa
pour saluer ses troupes.
Puis, ildu dans
la ville de Mykolaïv pour
constater l'ampleur des dégâts.
L'endroit est la cible
des forces russes depuis
le début de leur invasion.
Une frappe y a fait deux morts
et 20 blessés vendredi.
Cette ville portuaire et
industrielle est toujours
sous contrôle ukrainien,
mais l'étau se resserre pour
les combattants sur le terrain.
(tir) "Les soldats russes ont
plus d'armes et plus d'obus.
Ils bombardent surtout
les villages. On leur a tiré
dessus et ils se vengent
sur les quartiers
résidentiels," dit ce soldat
installé à l'arrière d'un
véhicule rempli de munitions.
"Nous devons travailler
rapidement et sortir de
la position aussi rapidement.
Nos vies en dépendent."
Et parmi les soldats qui sont
tristemeu combat,
on compte Roman Ratouchny,
tué alors qu'il avait 24 ans
dans la région de Kharkiv.
(chant en ukrainien)
Figure importante du mouvement
de protestation pro-européen
Maïdan en 2013, qui avait
provoqué le départ du président
prorusse Viktor Ianoukovitch
en 2014.
Ses funérailles ont attiré
des milliers de personnes
à Kiev, dont le maire de
la capitale, Vitali Klistchko.
(chant)
Plusieurs considèrent
ce jeune militant comme
un héros national.
"Je tiens à te remercier,
mon fils, pour tout ce que
tu as fait en si peu de temps.
Vois-tu combien de gens sont ici
aujourd'hui? Tu as changé
la vie de tant de personnes",a .
si je ne le connaissais
pas personnellement,
je le perçois comme une perte
personnelle. Roman est
une personne qui a influencé
ma vision du monde et qui
je suis maintenant", dit
cette jeune femme de 20 ans.
Ici Marie-Michell